today we're gonna be swapping ice creams
between Korean ice creams and American
ice creams everything is something fun
because I'm an honest stack it's mostly
on a stick or it's in a thick plastic
package that you can open up it just
screws I'm coming with an open mind and
an empty stomach I feel like your iTunes
gonna be great but America like we got
it online it's amazing it's an America
it's a classic it's orange vanilla
this one's called marijuana okay
marijuana it's a melon flavor very
simple rectangular cubic shape this is
also a very classic one but it's still
like really really cool to the music mmm
always like on the tops a lot more
softer than it's possible I think I feel
like mine
[Music]
hmm oh this is good or something inside
vanilla I feel just the bottom okay
I like that outside texture is kind of
like icy and the inside is a cream
let's bomb I really write I love this
it's soft its delicate it reminds me
before all the hoeing began innocence
it's very like vaguely Melanie it's
delicious it's creamy it's not like
brittle like if it's just water-based
like I think there's maybe some dairy in
this it's really delicious
I can't tie both amazing I'm actually
very Korean biased but I really like
this one fast and Swiss America oh it's
not too sugary so delicate sorry
it's like a pasta at me guys at me I
don't know what to say Korean one it's
called Peggy Bop literal translation is
pig bar I have no idea why it's called
pig bar is it bacon
this has nothing to do with pink it's
basically strawberry filling with
vanilla ice cream covered with chocolate
from this is strawberry shortcake carboy
Shortcake cream on top tell me the name
of your true love this is the one I want
you to spit all this it's the truest ice
cream bar of all time this crumbles on
the outside it's like very like vanilla
strawberry flavor they look like good
brothers yeah they're long-lost brothers
[Music]
cereal I love club I don't know if it
really tastes like strawberries or a
shortcake or a cake but it definitely
tastes pink and I know pink there's
jelly on the middle list which is kind
of confusing right
I like rope I like this too he's green
fancy this really fancy this tastes like
something you would serve at a
restaurant I'd like this one off they're
gonna go slightly different version but
it's like a chocolate bar with
strawberry filling throw a little bite I
need to decide okay so not saying that
one tastes all natural but this is very
artificial to speak great this I think
maybe because it's artificial it all
sort of like melts in your mouth as one
flavor we're wearing this you're getting
like different textures so I don't know
you know what I'm gonna go with the pink
this one yeah since because my favorite
color I can't decide so I can still like
this one too I think you think it's best
it like is so pretty it's very good Mr
Graham Yeah right about to say that
that's the thing that put it over the
edge I think they're both really good I
don't know but I feel I mean yeah I
don't think of it a tie I have the shoe
American classic the God of all ice
cream is the ones that's greater than
anyone that's ever existed an Ice Cream
Sandwich is it really literally the coal
ice cream sandwich there's more like
branding that the format is the name
Simon code is as you can see it's like
guppy shaped
yeah kind of like a cold fish yeah we're
gonna say it looks like a goldfish and
it has a little tasting kind of I know I
almost don't want to bite into it I took
a soft version of coing okay so my
biggest question is like what is the
deal with red beans it's it's so popular
in Korean desserts yeah
me personally I'm not a big fan of red
beans most of my finger friends kind of
freaked out when I said like oh do you
want like ice cream but there's red
beans inside into that one
oh it's so soft a little while so good
oh man
take my money oh yeah yeah have you been
into the red pina more it's actually
inside Oh
so you might have to take a second pipe
and you don't have to ask me twice
O'Hara football mhm here we've got a
little bean and then have a little bean
okay it's good yeah the bean flavor is
very mild and it's like plots up kind of
like cinnamon a uh-huh I like that the
sandwich part not to incite but I scream
pepper the sandwich part kind of reminds
me of the chocolate graham crackers I
have a little bit of saw here but not in
that not in a bad way this one I like it
she's young she's fresh she's ready for
the world
she just got her master's and like
cultural art or something she's about to
make the six digits yeah she's not to
make this such digit cuz she just got
married and she's in the stock yeah I
love it
she talks she's in it I I like this
better nice and --which yeah I think I
would choose that over at this even
though flavor-wise it's it's very
different I can yeah I can't pick on
flavor but this wins on pure give me
yeah convenience and size you could
double your money
exactly Wow
[Music]
what's up yeah we are presented by
topical this is actually my favorite
it's creamy chocolate flavored ice cream
which is in a plastic container I
thought so no mess whatsoever I have
seen some crazy [ __ ] in my time at
BuzzFeed I'm so intrigued by this right
now do you ever have a I see of the kid
oh it's it's like bad bigger it's a lot
thicker and mhm mhm yeah she's thick we
got the peanut chocolate shell you have
the vanilla ice cream you have the
waffle cone you have I think there's
like fudge sauce filling and then at the
bottom you've got like frozen chocolate
at the bottom oh there's like five
different layers you've got to get there
it's the whole ice cream I'm sold
and right there as you can see there's a
little plastic handle and then you pop
that I'll pop that and then you pull it
oh my boom boom and then you drink and
then you and then you eat it well not
really drink it right
oh well scrub mm-hmm look like chocolate
the hard part is you have to rub it or
twist it or bite into it to melt it I
just hope they don't run this into a gif
I would bite into the shell on the top
okay yeah hmm oh yeah that's really good
ice cream would be so satisfyingly messy
like if your ice cream isn't all over
your hands and face did you really eat
ice cream you did some great peanuts I'm
not gonna lie it's good I really like
the combination of the nuts and the
chocolate mmm
almost reminds me of sneakers mmm you
know yeah that's like Snickers like twin
sister oh yeah you know I could see that
I like this I mean that's good but this
is yeah poppy cool kind of takes the
cake I think so actually like this it's
like I'm gonna choose that one yes but
this is a close second do drumstick only
because I think I electron steak it's
gonna merican yeah
first of all this isn't the original
jazz bar or sushi bar so original joe's
bar looks like blue shark with deck yeah
a little popsicle stick inside of it and
when you bite into it it's a pink inside
and it's orange a strawberry flavor it's
like blood no it's like the inside of
the mouth basically this is the newer
version more safer to eat version in
America we have great white pops okay go
to somewhere but it's a lemon pop it
looks like a shark but it's a lemon pop
and it's white like a great white shark
now this is red white and blue true
America this is a bomb pop this is like
such an American thing and once again
now I know it doesn't look like it's
gonna create a mess these things are
messy but to live for driver you get it
all over your face if you're a little
kid it's like you would think the red
and the blue would mix together to
create a purple it's like a dark grey
purple and it just gets all over your
face on your tongue and it's super
sticky incredibly I'm not supposed to
fight this one yeah it's more like a
licking thing okay just so by the look
of it just looks like a dice you know
yeah I never know what white flavor is
an ice cream oh my that I don't know
what it is find out oh the red part
tastes like cherry but very artificial
flavor but I can see how it's very
American like when you look at it it's
very you know
well the artificial part is American to
accept lemonade ish I thought like
America yeah I don't know what Buddha's
like that face the blue it tastes like
just blue ice cream maybe they just like
got tired yeah they put all the effort
it was like you know what guys it's the
bottom part it doesn't have a distinct
flavor mm-hmm like I know it says orange
and strawberry it just tastes kind of
like frozen tropical and all of this I
think it's perfect packaging yeah like
the last a long time I think it's really
really
sweet but like not too sweet cuz I'm
like I'm not a sugar queen yeah that's a
classic but you don't get messy with
this they both taste artificial though
kind of like fun and like interactive
that's why I like it I'm team jealous
Ulysses going longer I like it it's very
lemony though it is light - like it's
basically just water and sugar I think
yeah gosh am i hypocritical I just rep
for America and I'm really enjoying you
know sometimes in life you know you have
to yeah you guys try something new if
you like it you have to go for it now I
liked a lot of both like the premier I
don't think there were any bad ones
whatever creating college there is their
major for ice cream packaging and design
is the best of the best and the
Americans are playing catch-up and it's
embarrassing
joy's it seems like you've enjoyed a lot
of Korean ice cream I think Koreans
really have the sugar game down yeah
like Koreans just really have the flavor
palate the it's just really good and
like I think American sweet though
delicious though bomb don't at me but we
can work yeah can't wait to go to Korea
yeah you know I got stuff all you are
choice T fever dream leave your dream
[Music]